okay let's go ahead and get started
thank you all for coming as those who
are regulars to our regular conference
know that occasionally we have
presentations at times other than 11:30
a.m. on Thursdays and we actually had to
do that today because we had a our
faculty two-for-one for our summer
interns so it actually gives me great
pleasure to introduce a colleague and
friend who when we found out he was
going to be passing through Portland we
made sure that we could capture some of
his knowledge and wisdom and he's
actually spoken in this room before has
have many luminaries and informatics in
the field from around the country in the
world and he's going to talk about what
I think is a real important and exciting
new thing and I know we have our summer
interns here who are very new to the
informatics field but this is really
important in fact I'm actually instead
of giving the usual introduction where I
would tell you that he went to Stanford
Medical School and he was the founding
chair of the department of biomedical
informatics at the University of Arizona
makes it gonna take a minute to let
everyone know why I think this is
important and I'm I really tried to get
a bunch of faculty here but Thursday
afternoon in the summer is the faculty
doesn't it doesn't always succeed but
the the work that Howard's going to talk
about is is one part and then there's
another part that's being done by
someone that that those who are faculty
in the field know very well Cindy GAD
from Vanderbilt these are the first
efforts to really try to define what
people who work in the field of
Informatics do and why is that important
well it's certainly important for the
physician part of the field which is
part although in that all of the field
in terms of the kind
of things that they need to know when
they are when they are trained in
informatics so they can go out and do
their work and the second piece which
he'll talk to it hasn't unlike his has
been published we all have access to it
it's acts I think it's open access so
anyone can get to it and and then the
second piece so so Howard's work focused
on the clinical informatics subspecialty
for physicians and then Cindy Gans work
is focusing on health informatics more
broadly although one of the interesting
things I actually heard a version of
this talk a couple months ago but I'm
looking forward to hearing again that
there's actually a lot of parallels and
some of the interesting comments but but
the the reason the reason why I'm hoping
that the faculty will really pay
attention to this rule really anyone is
because this is not only a good snapshot
of what's going on in the field but it
gives you a hint of where it's going and
the kinds of things that we in the
business of creating academic programs
need to think about
unfortunately we actually cover a fair
amount in our masters and PhD programs
on what's in the list that they've
uncovered but there are things and in
fact the the program at least while the
faculty may be others will probably have
a retreat after the second paper is
published so we can consider
modifications to our curriculum and so
forth so anyways I won't take too much
of more of his time but please listen
and I'm sure there'll be plenty of time
for discussion okay thanks Bill you know
you hear me it's the mic working in the
back because I'm a mom reader okay well
thank you Bill for that introduction and
I'm very happy to be here it is a it's a
deja vu but fortunately a pleasant one
from my part is that your will go into
that so yeah as bill said I'm really
here to convey kind of the data that's
coming out
studies and as you mentioned our two
sides of quota quota of the house a mia
has supported and put considerable time
effort and money into two studies one is
the CIS clinical informatics
subspecialty study to define what that
field is just a word about just worry
about the others health informatics
which is everybody that doesn't qualify
for the position pathway so health
informatics does include physicians
particularly physicians who for example
might have not maintained their primary
board certification so they're not
eligible to sit for the exam to the
practice pathway or get into a
fellowship or if we're strange outliers
like if you did a deal residency that's
not recognized by the American Board of
Medical Specialties etc so a chai side I
have the easy job because we have a
defined delimited population with email
addresses
Cyndi's study on a chai side was much
more complicated because they had an
undefined population that was very broad
I'm gonna touch on a little bit of a
chai stuff I'm not really
I wasn't centrally involved in that but
I have gotten Cindy's permission to
reuse some of her slides and this is an
evolving story and hopefully it will be
so just quickly on the CIS side the
original work was done by the famous
gardner paper a whole group of people
that wrote two papers in around 2009
published them on the core content of
clinical informatics and the program
requirements for clinical informatics
fellowships and it is essentially a
knowledge taxonomy that's quite robust
and almost unusable because some things
are they're covered in depth some things
aren't it would also a pretty much an
expert opinion it was just kind of a
group of people got together primarily
academics to create it the good news is
that it got us started and it's it's
it's not optimal but it's not it's good
so after 10 years turns out the fields
changed a little bit in 10 years plus it
became more and more apparent that we
needed a more robust defensible
methodology by which we could define the
field and there is an industry standard
called practice analysis but it always
to me felt a little bit more like we're
trying to figure out how to create a
platypus you know it was tough to get
our arm
around what this really meant so I'm
gonna walk you through kind of the
methodology and some of the results
please pipe up and ask questions as we
go but try to have a somewhat high
threshold for questions so we don't get
too bogged down and then we have
microphones or I'll repeat the questions
if we need to because I know this is
being did you guess so here my learning
objectives I won't read through these
[Music]
yeah so we're gonna talk about the
practice analysis methodology and the
differences between the two studies
these this is a Doug fritzman slide
which I love the graphic on here so I
montón Lee stole it from him
clinical informatics specialist because
freaking miracle worker is an official
job title and there is this concern
without a definition in the field that
only can't we align our training
programs with the certification exam but
we can't tell the US government what the
job is that information does and there
are some benefits of having federal job
codes and so on especially for workforce
development so what we wanted to do is a
systematic analysis and it turns out
that this is common in other industries
and there are consultants who do this
for a living who know what they're doing
so we wrote an RFP we put it out for
consultants got several bids back we
looked through it all and we decided to
partner with a CT Pro exam some of you
may have taken the ECT exam right for
college so that's a big outfit and they
know what they know what they're doing
and they were just the best consultants
I've ever worked with and I don't say
that more than once per lifetime all
right okay so there's two elements once
a structured consensus process to
develop the delineation of practice now
this is going to be we're going to come
back to this gonna pause a little on
these terms for domains tasks and
knowledge and skills and knowledge and
skills I'm going to just probably refer
to as either chaos or knowledge so again
I mentioned the Gartner paper was a
knowledge document what really matters
to us in training programs are what does
the fellow need to be able to do right
or the dissertation student the PhD or
master's student and it then needs to be
validated by going out to people who are
actually doing that and say does this
sound right is there something wrong
here is there something missing
something not clear
so those are the two elements of the
methodology to inform as I mentioned
training requirements and eligibility
requirements for certification defense
ability of an assessment program meaning
how can we assess a learner if we don't
know what they're supposed to know or
what they're supposed to be able to do
so knowing that really helps to do the
assessment part certification
examination specs we talked about and
amia took a leadership role in this and
I you know I don't own stock and Amy and
I'm not trying to like sell their goods
but they really did make a significant
investment of effort intellectual effort
staff time and finances and this was the
CIS and the H I studies have both are
both bore a me aboard approved documents
so this has gone through a tremendous
amount of scrutiny it was really fun
doing all that I can tell you how much
fun that was all right
I'm the CIS side to support it through
the organizations listed CIC o P for
those that don't know is the clinical
informatics community of practice this
is all the people who have passed the
subspecialty exam
that's the see is I see CIPD is the
clinical informatics program director
group fellows and a BPM American Board
of preventive medicine who administers
the examination cindy side of the house
on health informatics certification and
there is not currently a certifying body
for that so this is the first step to be
able to provide a certification
infrastructure is to create the
delineation of practice that says here's
what it is to be a health and
fermentation then create the certifying
body then create the exam and then so
you know getting people through the
pipeline okay and I've already covered
this the practice analysis with the
update to Gardner and this is you know
again data-driven process a robust
process to come up with these and this
is the unofficial emblem of the program
director organization and I understand
bill were to be credited for this round
hole
Ramon was a polished performer but this
was sheer madness is a square peg in a
round hole unassisted in a blindfolded
so this really has is if you want to be
an information you've got to master this
act in many cases now up at the top that
hyperlink and I'm hoping that these
slides will be available if not you know
you can always email me but now if you
click through they'll take you directly
to the CIS article which was published
back in May there are supplements to
this that article that digital
supplements that have the full
delineation of practice and the data on
which it was based so if you want to
take a look at that it's easy to get to
the health informatics is in process of
being written the delineation the work
is all done they're writing it up it's a
much more complicated thing to write up
so they anticipated they hope to have
that out but in November a Mia meeting
and it looks like it'll be after I've
been told after the first of the year
not too far after that it'll probably
look a lot like this obviously different
data a different process and we're going
to cover a little bit of that okay so
our aims were you know again to to
articulate the tasks and competencies
used in practice and then the skills the
knowledge that support that practice so
what do you do that's why when I asked
everybody what do you do day-to-day the
blueprints exam blueprints and then as a
former recovering fellowship director
this should be a closed loop right so
should have the delineation of practice
dictates with the fellowship
accreditations require the fellows be
taught that is lined with the
examination certification process and
that is aligned with subsequent
maintenance of certification after
you've been certified simple I mean what
could be easier and that's the last
point is the maintenance of
certification so we conducted this in
two and a half phases phase one was
convening a practice analysis task force
so what we did is we sent to the entire
CI COP list so we sent through all its
currently certified CIS diplomats an
invitation to become involved in this
process we asked them for a bunch of
information about the current job role
where they are you know the usual kinds
of things and which of the following
would you be interested
- then and there were you'll see in a
minute I have a graphic I think makes a
little clearer we were writing different
groups that we formed now we spent a
long time picking these twelve subject
matter experts so that they were diverse
in every aspect we could think of
different locations different some work
for VA some were vendors some were for
academics gender you can name it
everything we could think of to get what
we thought was going to be a really
robust and diverse panel because
obviously this group is critical they're
coming up with this initial delineation
of practice there's going to be
subsequent refinement of that but they
they have to land somewhere in the
landing zone right or it's not gonna
work which we did and it turned out in
retrospect we did a really good job
because this group was amazing one of
the people who is a full-time academic
as he was leaving the meeting I said
what did you think of the process in the
outcome he said these people are amazing
I had no idea that these people existed
out there because he's pretty much more
pure academics but he was very
complimentary so that was a good sign
you know that there was agreement about
how well this group did so the group
brainstorm domains what are the major
domains by the definition the domain
should be the domain should be mutually
exclusive but comprehensive the union of
which should represent the whole field
right then under each domain tasks and
then knowledge and skills
the consultants did a really nice job we
shoveled a ton of information to them
every article we could find they we gave
them a variety of different subject
matter experts and people in the field
who knew the history other people who
had various types of jobs and they
interviewed all these people and they
came up with a several page briefing
document for the face-to-face meeting
that this group had to establish that
initial draft delineation of practice
the idea was then in Phase two we were
fine that then we take that delineation
of practice and we send it out to the
back to the CIS diplomat community and
say does this look right and we'll go
into how we did that in detail in just a
second so we want to verify that the
this updated core content and we wanted
to gather
data for downstream use clinical
downstream use cases which is fellowship
training requirements to be changed
fellowship milestones to be updated
maintenance of certification things I
mentioned earlier but we knew this is a
one-time chance to add questions on the
other hand if we added too many
questions no one would complete the
survey so this is was there interesting
balancing act and this is where having a
good consultant who has done this like a
lot was really really helpful at where
to put the set point on that so my
apologies a little small maybe in the
back of the room but get out your
binoculars I'll walk you through this
was the CIS overview of the process the
project was initiated at the AMIA level
with the selection of the consultant
there was an oversight kind of an
executive steering group to this
operation that's the group I'd say I was
asked to chair then there were 12
practice analysis task force members pH
EF secondary review panel and a pilot
survey review panel okay so what
happened during phase one was that the
pH EF met for this two-day meeting which
was in Chicago and I remember coming out
of that meeting and I couldn't find the
elevator that's how during neuro
chemically drained I was but it was
actually really fun I mean I I don't
know why I would think this was fun but
it was really cool to be really
wrestling with his you know these
questions and the amount of talent in
the room was unbelievable okay that then
went out to a second independent
secondary review panel okay another
group of SMEs who we had also chosen
with that same diversity requirement
they got feedback this isn't clear this
is missing this should be there and then
we had a whole process to refine that
feedback brought it back to the P ATF to
say okay what do you think of this input
Phe F looked at it comes to the
oversight panel there are many of you
know internal approvals I haven't
depicted here and that led us to the
composition of a draft delineation of
practice which included the domains
tasks and knowledge statements which
I'll show you the numbers in a second
that then was put into a survey
instrument
which I'm going to talk about also in a
minute was sent to a third independent
group of SMEs
to say look at this does this there's a
survey instrument work can you navigate
it is this too long to send out is there
something else that's missing should we
be asking the questions in a different
way it was more kind of testing the
survey methodology rather than asking
for their actual survey input then it
went out to all CIS diplomats with the
exception of anybody who had touched it
along the pathway to its generation
right so I got a link it went out to all
CIS diplomats to the a BPM and a B path
American Board of pathology so I got a
link to it and I called a consultant
said do I fill this out they said no you
can't fill it out you already you know
you've already had your skin in the game
okay so and that led to the composition
of this final GOP which then went to the
Board of Directors at a Mia for final
approval which we got last November so
the question that we had was how many
are going to return this survey we
figured it would take about 45 minutes
to an hour these are all really busy
people we had hoped our our dream was to
get 300 back from the 1695 and as you
can see we actually exceeded that by a
little bit now I was initially kind of
disappointed because it's like 80% of
people didn't return this but in talking
with the consultants it was interesting
they said that usually they average
about four to ten percent return so they
were thought this was fabulous
they did some statistical calculations
and felt that even at that level they
were pretty confident that these were
results we could defend now what we
would like to have done was take our
demographics which is extensive take a
demographic analysis of the respondents
and that included things like job title
and role and all that kind of stuff and
compare it to the full 1695 ABM p.m.
diplomats guess who has that data nobody
turned out the a BPM had no date on
these candidates at all except for what
year they graduated medical school
please don't repeat that in public I'm
not trying to criticize a BPM it was
amazing that they got the thing off the
ground in the first place anyway is not
surprising they forgot the Nesquik you
know when they got to the moon but so we
had nope there were the comparable
analysis was just not even possible it
probably still is I still don't think
they're gathering how much
or we felt pretty confident that we
could take these results forward with
confidence we did however bring the
demographic comparison the demographic
snapshot that we did have from our
survey respondents we brought that back
to the P ATF and say take a look this
does this look reasonable do you think
this is like way out of line like
there's way too many people to VA or way
too many people in academics or whatever
in pH F said no this is we think this is
this is us we think it's good that gave
us some confidence that we could move
forward to refine this so I mentioned
the survey itself that's going to ask
for show hands of how many you completed
this but I know you're all in training
and I don't end Barriss bill and Vishnu
so okay so these are the questions we
ask how frequently did you perform this
task this is four tasks right and how
important so something that's performed
infrequently but it's very important you
want to know about so we got all this
data back on all the tasks turned out
there were 42 tasks and about 142
knowledge statements so imagine doing
the survey it seems simple these two
questions but you're doing it across
roughly 170 statements it was you know
took time in additional the demographic
questions now for survey knowledge the
consultants always call this knowledge
and skill to me this is knowledge skills
our tasks but anyway nomenclature we
asked the karate questions again
frequency which we asked for tasks but
we didn't ask how important is the
knowledge we asked two other questions
what level of mastery the knowledge
should be required at the time of
certification which is a surrogate for
saying what should be taught in
fellowships because the time of
certification will be at the end of your
fellowship now in the practice pathway
which is still open you can take the
exam without a fellowship but that's
going to close in a year or two so this
is important feedback for informing
after use case of program requirement
revisions for accrediting planning and
implementing and accrediting informatics
fellowships and then we specifically
announced how important is this to
include in a fellowship it's kind of a
little bit
this question was given to all program
directors so we know who the program
directors were we sent them that
question and in fact what we had to do
because we didn't want to ask three
questions across 170 something things to
all respondents the consultants had seen
this before they saw this is easy we
just create two versions of the survey
we asked everybody frequency of use but
one half of them get level of mastery
the other half get this one half gets
the question on the left the other half
gets the question on the right so that
worked out pretty well and it turned out
as you see by the respondents we had
pretty given distribution between those
two okay so the final delineation of
practice was looking at what we got on
the returns primarily on frequency and
importance for the purposes of this
delineation and the mean frequency
ratings had to be 2.5 or more at least
rarely too occasionally and importance
ratings of three or more and I'm gonna
go back for a second if you look at
frequency see frequency has five choices
I'm gonna go back to the prior slide and
importance has four that's why there's a
little difference in kind of a
point-to-point thing okay and here's
what we came up with I mentioned the 42
and 139 now this for the first time
shows you the domain structure so domain
1 fundamentals there no test and it paid
it's basic knowledge so there no tasks
in domain 1 improving care delivery
outcomes Enterprise Information says i'm
mridu they're there okay so this was and
you can see that there's a pretty good
distribution of tasks and knowledge
statements across these four domains
which again mutually exclusive I also on
the backend created a little cheat sheet
which was a map of the task statements
to knowledge statements so there usually
were several knowledge statements that
supported a task so internally we also
have a map that map as well that will be
useful for fellowship and training
programs to know for this task this is
the knowledge we have to teach them to
do that task the prerequisite knowledge
or at least think about think about okay
so as I said this this is kind of like
that
content 2.0 whatever you want to call it
but for the first time now includes task
information not just knowledge that was
new the thing that we saw as a definite
pattern was that data analytics and data
governance turns out to be important duh
so when we're in the middle of doing
this the program directors they're all
frantically calling me saying we're not
calling but saying oh my god how am I
gonna have to change my whole fellowship
curriculum it's like no relax because
the fellowship directors already know
that this is important and already
teaching it so that most of us not all
the fellowships were already
forward-leaning and knew that they had
to teach this stuff even though it was
never specified of the 58 or 59 sub
competencies that are required to teach
fellows and these accredited fellowships
1im data analyze and query data yeah
it's unbelievable to me okay so this
reflects the current state of the art to
where data is becoming really really
important okay so let me pause for a
second pause that refreshes before we
get into health informatics any any
questions about I know I went kind of
really quickly through this okay you
still with me right where we go okay now
into health informatics which I'm going
to cut at Cindy GAD four we had a we had
a mutual agreement pact that we could
use each other's slides but basically
she had this she even had a rounder peg
in the round and a square hold to this
because of the diversity and the lack of
a really defined population within
health informatics so they cast the net
very broadly and for those of you who
have been following to play-by-play over
the last couple years this has been a
very difficult and arduous effort to get
this thing put together okay so this is
a new certification so there's nothing
available at the moment but there are
things available but there's no standard
really like we had with Gartner like it
or not at least it was something you
could push against this there's an
implication of this it's very important
there is a certifying body and a
certifying process for the physician
side that's American Board of preventive
medicine there's currently no certifying
body there's no one that administers the
exam for this future credential so
that's something Amy is really trying to
work out because that there are all
sorts of requirements for
for one to be able to call oneself a
certifying entity and if a mia becomes
that certifying entity then they cannot
conduct review courses to prepare you
for the exam that they're certifying
right that's an ethical problem there
has to be a firewall built between so in
the case of the physicians the American
Board preventive medicine administers
its exam Oh hsu stanford others and a
mia can provide with me of courses
that's fine as long as you don't have
exam item writers going back and forth
between the two the audience is more
diverse as I've said over and over again
by the way that audience is not nurses
and pharmacists that audience is
everybody masters level people PhDs
everybody that does work in informatics
it's a very big tent now we talked about
this we decided not to do this on the
physician side except for that level of
mastery prior to certification but they
very explicitly looked at the difference
between mid-career and advanced
practitioners trying to glean some
insights about what tests and knowledge
are required earlier in your career
what's required later because of the
diversity of that audience that makes a
big difference in some professions and
not in others it doesn't make that big a
difference for the physicians that's
right the H eyesight okay so this is the
slide I showed you earlier this is the
CIS slide and now quick change this is
the age I practice looks pretty familiar
right the things that are different are
these so they add a secondary they had
yet another level which is the focus
panels and secondary review panels yeah
actually have a little error on that
slide so what they wound up realizing is
that they needed such broad input they
couldn't just rely they couldn't get
enough people on any one group to do
that so they they added and spun out
three additional focus panels I think
they sort of specialty specific I'm now
where the details of these to take a
look at those aspects and be sure they
all lined up I think it was a good move
because it gave them an extra level of
due diligence to be sure they were
trying to be as broad as they could in
terms of points of view being harvested
and collated the rest of it
same secretary review panel
survey practice analysis survey final
GOP right this went on and just
concluded last January that's why
they're a little bit behind us in terms
of getting that's written up and had a
lot more we have 25 SMEs and volunteers
across those four panels they had 60 so
could they intentionally needed to have
a lot more constituencies represented so
it can imagine choreographing all that
since they had no defined group to send
the survey to they partnered with a lot
of different organizations to get the
survey out so and they often you know
they sent the survey link to them and
then they send it on to their members so
they didn't even know how many went out
they knew what they got back but they
didn't know what the denominator was so
there's no percentage you know on that
1011 return surveys it's hard to know
what the end is on the bottom but
nonetheless a significant number of
completed surveys which was great
and here's just a kind of high level
snapshot of the respondents for the H
eyes primary domains medicine I'm
assuming means physicians usually that's
what that would mean that again as I
said earlier might not have access to
the certification pathway through the
American Board of Preventive Medicine
and then Public Health Pharmacy nursing
others and H I not related to specific
help that main probably means people
that are not clinic don't have clinical
backgrounds that's what that would
account for and that's a significant
number as well that might be people who
have training and master's degree or a
PhD and informatics who are working in
various capacities in the field okay so
the task ratings were the same as the
CIA SP I showed you earlier frequency
and importance then they also asked
under knowledge and skills some
additional questions well frequency
again same but then instead of the what
level of master Asia to be on
fellowships they added this question who
needs to know this and this is the
career stage question and again for
knowledge not for tasks if you look at
the final delineation of practice again
not published but we this has already
been presented in other meetings I'm
going to show you this side-by-side with
CIS but I'll just tell you that
independently the domain structure
looked curiously the same now that's
actually
gave me a good feeling Joe is like
totally different you'd really wonder
what's wrong with this picture right so
it's kind of reassuring that it looks
somewhat the same the thing that was
remarkable is that there are
significantly more task statements
there's 74 and about the same number
knowledge statements and let me put the
I think the next one is Oh No yeah so so
there were a lot more so I asked
specifically since I wasn't directly
involved in this how come there's so
many more task statements and the staff
and Cindy said we're not sure we think
it's probably because of the stage of
career that the p8 that the P 80 F for
the health informatics I'd really tried
to be much more broad covering a lot
more territory between different
professions and different levels and so
that initiated a lot more task
statements what was interesting that the
knowledge statements were in terms of
numbers were about the same
okay so I've covered this already but
just to recap you know these are the
downstream use cases for the see is we
have subsequently then with Amyas
support and encouragement convened a
group of program directors I asked for
their 37 accredited programs CIA's
fellowship programs as of two weeks ago
changes daily but we had eight
volunteers who agreed to go through the
entire CIS delineation of practice and
say how do we do we need to keep this
four fellows should this be required of
fellows what should be required to
fellows do we need to reword any of
these statements and spent days and days
doing this that went out to a second
group of four program directors to look
and critique of what the original group
of programmers have done so this
actually has already done that we've
prepared a summary of the process and
the results to go to the RSC as an input
into the training program requirements
revisions which we hope will happen in
2020 and of course with the H I side
same kind of thing they specifically
mention educational program
accreditation requirements that's the
equivalent of the CAS fellowship
accreditation requirements and so it's
dr. Hirsch mentioned this has potential
implications hard to know whether this
will be a ship in the night or whether
this become a standard that educational
programs will look to adhere to that
remains
certainly it should inform from Amyas
perspective their programming and
curricula and CIS nhi curricula criminal
roadmaps
and then the big interesting part we've
all been waiting for us what's the
crosswalk how do these two affiliations
of practice compare and is there some
kind of then in which some stuff is
really pretty much the same that
overlaps and there's some stuff that's
different and and if so is it a little
bit as a big van what how's that going
to look so that's currently underway I
was asked by a Mian not to disclose that
because it hasn't really matured yet and
secondly the H I've studies not yet
published so as I said they'll come out
in January and we hope to have this
crosswalk done and probably be published
in the spring of next year
oh I did put them side-by-side so here
I'm not going to read this but if you
glance up and down you'll see that
there's a striking similarity to the two
domain the domain structure of the two
in fact a really no different except for
a couple words here and there very
interesting you can if you want to get
more into it say okay where where are
the differences in numbers and the
biggest one was in domain three on
health informatics had a huge number of
tasks they've had over twice as many
chance statement says or almost twice as
many as the enterprise information
systems under the CIS domain so there is
a correspondence between these two so I
also asked the question since CIS went
first and then H I that they just copy
off of our paper I mean what happened
there in that room and they said no they
had access to the CIS delineation
practice but they intentionally went
about the exercise de novo and then did
kind of a back and forth a little bit to
see kind of if they wanted to borrow
anything from the H I side they also use
the Gardner document as we did as an
input so it's not surprising that the
knowledge statements would tend to look
somewhat more similar okay so we imagine
in addition to the use cases I mentioned
that there's a lot of interesting things
that could come of this to help
educational programs focus to help
employers focus because if I'm sitting
looking to hire
either health informatics person or
clinical informatics subspecialists I
know how have a job description that I
can choose from you know here's there's
42 skills that you should have well I
don't expect that of everybody so here
the most important ones in our
organization for this level of hire so
maybe you don't have to know how to you
know project management or governance
and on that kind of stuff but you should
know that data analytics part if we're
hiring to analytics so it gives you a
menu to choose from for job descriptions
and overall will strengthen the
profession we had a little exercise
earlier with the fellows about can you
do a 10 or 15 second explanation of what
it is you do and I would challenge
anybody to do that but it's not easy and
I said this morning my kids always said
he's a doctor and he does other stuff we
don't understand so that's not an
adequate explanation of what it is you
do if you're talking with friends
neighbors and employers okay so that's
really Mike my comments for today and
I'll kind of how are we doing on time we
got plenty of times for questions and I
know I went through this pretty quickly
and it's in some ways not exactly super
exciting but it has huge implications
for all of us in the room so I think we
have time to wait for the mic to travel
thank you for your talk for those of us
who may be less familiar with where the
clinical informatics fellowships are
physically based as what kind of
institutions they're at could you
perhaps talk a little bit about whether
there's any differences in what you see
the respondents saying based on the
demographics you know is somebody at an
East Coast academic health center
responding very differently for compared
to a clinical informatics program that
might be in a more networked rural or
mixed kind of community do you have any
sense of demographic differences in the
needs the answer is no there no there's
no difference at least on the CIS side
the consultants did extensive subgroup
analyses based on age based on location
they could not determine any
statistically significant differences
obviously you have to roll up the data
so there could be isolated instances of
outliers but that was actually
reassuring that we didn't see some big
trend where the East Coast is entirely
different than the West Coast in terms
of how they define their tasks and
knowledge and skill requirements
I believe it was done on the CI a-- h i
side i just don't know for sure and
before i forget your question also
remind me at another point it's very
interesting when you do they crosswalk
looking at the initial crosswalk we run
into a terminology issue i wouldn't say
it's a problem but everywhere on the CIS
side that says clinical informatics
everywhere on the h i said it says
health informatics so we're gonna have
to have some like process maybe a tug of
war something i don't know to figure out
what the term is that we use and i'm
because it's like medical informatics no
it's clinical informatics okay
everybody's cool with that no no we're
not cool about now let's get health
informatics so i know maybe we'll just
agree to disagree in you know have some
cross map that says you know health
slash clinical informatics there's that
difference to that we'll have to look at
if the data is further analyzed so yeah
it's a great question thank you doctor
question as you you know correctly
stated the the emergence of the fifth
domain of data analytics and governance
is no surprise at all are there were
there any things though that were
surprises you know in terms of you know
cuz i think we have a kind of general
idea of what informations do in
hospitals and and so forth but was there
anything that stood out and and and then
maybe a second question is are there any
are there any things that you think are
important trends in the field that that
didn't show up and and you know because
we're taking a snapshot in time which is
already what a year old you know are
there new things coming down the pike
yeah both great questions and actually
there's one answer for both so sir
really wasn't anything that was terribly
surprising that was like an out like oh
we never thought of that there we when
we convened the CISPA TF we said we want
you to think about now and the next five
years roughly next five to ten but more
like now to five years with it thought
that the practice should be repeated
every five to ten years probably an
informatics more in the earlier side
because iterative change so we want to
be forward leaning so there were a
couple things on the CIS side that
were in there that got very low
frequency and importance ratings so I'll
give you two examples I had mentioned
earlier to the group international
clinical informatics was the knowledge
thing that was carried over from Gartner
that was in the original DOP on a survey
it got like zero rating so if you ask
the average CMIO - to you how important
is international clinical informatics
and often to use that it's always zero
right so that we decided to strike
because we didn't we thought that was
good information and we'll take it out
by the way all of these strikes were not
done by me or by the consultants and
it's done all that was brought back to
the PhD F with a set of with here's the
data here's our thinking on it what do
you think there were originally 142
knowledge statements and so we refined
some of them those were left out what
was interesting were the forward leaning
ones they also got low importance and
frequency example social determinants of
health incorporating incorporating
bioinformatics data into the EHR a
couple of those like that
that are clearly they're clearly
important they should be kept even
though they're forward-leaning so you
get interesting a dynamic so we brought
all this back to the PhD F and without
trying to prejudice and we said no so
that here's one we think we should
eliminate here's others we should
discuss what do you think and everybody
said we need to leave these in because
they're not what visit what information
see a physician in fermentations are
doing today but it's not that far it's
probably before the next redo of this
that that'll come into the floor so that
was actually kind of cool now what was
surprising to me was in Congress some
conversations of a BPM they were not
happy about that because they said well
if it's they're not doing that we don't
know how to test them I had to remind
them that they can decide to test
whatever they want
now they don't have to do that we're
going to keep it in the donation
practice it's up to you guys to decide
where the focus is for the actual
examination so this year you may not
test it next year you might say oh no we
have enough about stuff going on it we
could write some test questions so yeah
but beyond that there wasn't anything
super surprising I think probably the
real value wasn't so much that we
discovered something new but I think we
put it into a very robustly
first of all we had we had a process
that we think now backs it up it's not
been
someone's opinion or just a small group
of people's opinion and the number of
sanding and polishing of worry it's
unbelievable how much work went into
refining the statements to be as clear
as possible and this brief as possible
so that's a little bit new yeah and the
other of course is just having a task
list which we never had before but no
other no they're shockers I don't know
you'd be probably Lance to the CIS
delineation oh if there was anything
that struck you yeah I don't wanna put
you on the spot for having memorize it
what's number 42 but no I don't think
there's anything that's so surprising
that's why I said I didn't think the
program director shouldn't be too
worried about it because they're already
doing this stuff plus you know most of
us have had site visits you know besides
visitors know nothing about informatics
and mine said so what are y'all doing
here computers so like okay it's gonna
be a great visit so we're still way
better than you know with a CG means
other questions or comments
he's got one of things
okay Joan and then Vishnu thank you for
such a clear presentation I was on
regard neurs committee for developing
the original core competencies and we
kept in mind through the entire process
CMIO SCM iOS
CM iOS and I suspect this is much
broader than that I'm wondering what you
kept in mind the whole time you were
going through your process for the CIS
piece of it well I would say diversity
so you're you know you were one into my
understanding that group it was more
academic so you had to really kind of
work a little bit to remember wait a
second there's a broader constituency we
subvert of that need by just having them
in the room which is really quite
remarkable and we didn't know if it was
going to work we didn't know you know if
you choose the wrong people in terms of
you they're what they're representing
which part of the universe of
representing or they're creepy people or
they've got to be in their bonnet about
you know fire you know what some
specific thing but we didn't get any of
that so that was really amazing that's
what I was most concerned about that
we've got a loser
we got a loser group there was one
person in ours who was disruptive and it
just took some basic group management to
straighten that out pretty quick that
always happens so no no you're not in
that group there over there remember sit
down please so just it was innocent it
was well well-intentioned it's a good
question
I can't comment for Cindy I don't know I
know it's obviously a more complex
environment I know they struggled
immensely more than we did about the
diversity of representation with good
cause yeah dr. Mullen so so my question
is now that you're like done with the
process and you have a sense of of this
how often do you think we should be
doing this as a specialty I mean
typically for GME we do these kind of
updates to the to the clinical field
that's usually in cycles of 10 years or
15 years
I mean clearly informatics kind of works
in dog years so as we've seen from 2009
to now the field has grown a lot so
what's the optimum time to be doing this
exercise again to get current with the
field yeah so this is a good question
and of course we asked our consultants
what do you think is the industry
standard for this and they said it
really varies depending on how fast and
you know a field is changing and they
agree that from everything they have
learned through the process informatics
is more rather than less changing what
we put in our article was we recommended
every seven to ten years I probably
would have myself said every five to
seven but it is a arduous process to go
through number one number two the a BPM
will freak out if they get a new exam
blueprint mandate every five years it
takes them three years to create an exam
you know it's a lot of work now that
will get easier and it I asked when
Chris layman was still there I asked
them is there anything here that so
outlandish that you won't be able to
cover it on an exam you said no this is
actually reassuring because I think we
have content already questions already
so it may be a simple in the exam part
of it
it's just reclassifying the questions
and mapping them today but probably
every five to seven years that's I think
we put in the paper seven to ten just to
be a little bit on not to put anybody's
feet to the fire I would not wait ten
it's way too long we'll probably have to
for the program requirements but but
those are loosey-goosey anyway they can
you have a lot of leeway as a program
director to work around some stuff there
and maybe it'll slow down I mean maybe
we've seen the rapid change between 2009
and now because of the stimulus bill and
all the amazing activity will enter on
it went on around HR instruction so we
may also see us slowing down so that has
to be kind of a calculation of how much
is it going to cost in terms of time and
money how fast is the field changing
does this still feel like it's
representative we'll see
fortunately I'm dropping the mic my
favorite expression used to be how hard
can that be now it's how hard can that
be and what can possibly go wrong with
this plan and that's difficulty when you
get into this kind of stuff it's it's
you know to come up with a methodology
that's efficient but robust that's
defensible and meaningful it's it's
tricky we were I think in some ways
fortunate that it kind of landed you
know in one piece I don't want to hog
the microphone other people have
questions but seeing no others for right
now
there's a bunch of people in this room
not only the current trainees but others
who are wondering and you may or may not
know this what what the sort of next
steps are for the exam incorporating
this into the exam you know it's not
only are people gonna be taking it at
some point soon but those who do board
review courses and advise people it did
do you know what a bpm and whoever else
ACGME have planned in terms of I give
you this is not accurate to ten decimal
places I'm remembering a conversation
with Adi who inherited Chris's position
as chief of the exam he said I'll take
it two or three years to retool the exam
and they could probably do the exam
faster but they have to have enough time
to get a new blueprint out to the people
that are going to be taking the exam and
you'd have time for people who are
offering review courses to readjust to
that blueprint so the whole as you know
better name but there's a whole series
of steps that it does require some lead
time it could be done faster but there's
it would it would short-circuit a lot of
those other steps would be a problem
it's it's interesting though because the
blueprint for the first exam was
basically the reproducing the the table
that was in the Gardner paper and that
won't be the case because we're actually
thinking with the board review course
that the exam is is gonna change
significantly next year 2020 it's
possible I don't know by the way we we
gave the a BPM so we also asked
questions to establish an example of
print so what an example in purpose is
is amongst these domains that I showed
you earlier
what percentage of questions should be
within each of those domains totally 100
obviously percent so we asked the
respondents should this be on a
certification examination and then we
asked them separately amongst these
domains what percentage should each of
these be on an example of Brits we had
two ways of looking at that data we
compiled that and we intentionally at a
BPMS request left it out of the article
which I think was the right move because
a BPM didn't want anything in print
I misinterpreted it as an a BPM endorsed
example who print so but that was all
that data was given to the a BPM and in
their mysterious processes they will end
there some unspecified time for it and
cook it up but you know I think people
like audience oh and they must I know
that they've got to be chewing on this
and they've got to probably some be
extending some kind of work plan I'm not
sure what their plans are in terms of
communication about what that timeline
is you have to ask them but there's a
clear map of the process ahead how long
it's going to take anybody's guess but I
remember him saying to me two to three
years just because of the other things I
mentioned which are attached not just
the exam so data data analytics isn't
important for two or three more years
yeah well that's the good part is we're
all teaching it because we know it's
important yeah yeah and and you know
that I mean what I found you know it's
funny because you know we were the first
year we did the board review course our
our sort of Oracle of knowledge was been
monger who you know helped develop the
subspecialty and had you know previously
developed the emergency medicine
subspecialty and he's like there will be
you know there won't be much new things
you know things that are relatively
recent you you may have heard me tell
this story and you know so the first
year the board review of course we
really kind of played down Meaningful
Use you know even though it was 2013 or
2014 I can't one of those years but so
you know Meaningful Use had been around
for a few years but there was nothing in
the outline that talked about it so we
said to the people taking the board of
course you know don't don't really worry
you know about meaningful use so sure
enough when I go to take the exam myself
about the third or fourth question and
there's there's a question about stage 2
meaningful use which had just started
yeah and but you know in reality you
know that you can even go back into the
original Gardner categories and and you
know kind of tease out things that are
happening now that you want
you know that you could attribute to
things that are in it back then so I you
know I'm sure the exam and we know for a
fact the exam has evolved and you know
maybe it will evolve before the all the
new study guides and everything come out
yeah and we know that you know the
reality is that no one's gonna very few
people are gonna get hundred percent on
a board sort of certifying exam so
they're gonna be things like that
did either escape your awareness when
you were going through your studies it
wasn't covered or just you just know
it's gonna be on the exam but obviously
a BPM does want to get too specific so
that's why they're gonna just release
percentages in each domain and then you
could but at least now you'll be able to
see what is in that domain and it a BPM
could go off-road and create questions
that aren't tied to those tasks or
knowledge statements put my senses they
probably have a big incentive to be sure
that so you'd have a outer circle of
what they with the exception of these
evolving things this is similar to that
they mentioned earlier about these
evolving areas and when they might since
it's in the DOP when they might put in
questions about that like they your
example meaningful use is exactly the
same thing I don't know just depends
when they they divine that it's now
relevant enough and frequent enough to
in their opinion include on exam so yes
I just have a quick favor to ask of you
I think a lot of people in this room are
at various levels of experience in
history with the field of Informatics
and you all have dropped a lot of names
and not necessarily helped us understand
so like I know who read Gardner is but
I'm not sure that everybody else in the
room does and you keep talking about
Audie who's chairing the new exam
committee but who is that and what's
their background and where are they
located I think giving us a little bit
of that might help us understand who's
shaping our field in these ways so Joan
mentioned that she worked with regard oh
no regard nur but his paper is
frequently referred to as the Gardner
paper so in that respect I would say if
you go back to the recently published
papers published in November that had
that link up there and actually let me
quickly go all the way back so in case
you didn't you know
I mean we call it the gardener paper
because read garden was the first author
it was there were a lot of people
involved Joan and others so so really
really we should be saying the original
core content outline and not the
gardener paper but for whatever reason
that Utah University Utah he was the
chair of the informatics program there
but you know he was just the the kind of
chair of the committee and there were
many others in the field many names you
would recognize yeah yeah so that
article is referenced here and the
article we wrote has a fair amount of
history of all this stuff and how these
organizations came together your point
is well-taken and I don't know I can't
pronounce Oddie's last name otherwise I
would have given you his full name but
really substitute for it Audie the chair
of the a BPM exam committee that's
that's the role that he occupies it's
not him that's that important but that's
that group so a BPM the American Board
of Preventive Medicine has multiple sub
boards for clinical informatics there is
a chair of vice-chair of the exam
committee and they're about 20 people
that write items for them no no no no
because the the you can become certified
in clinical informatics irrespective of
specialty you just have to have had at a
BMS primary specialty or fellowship so I
think he's an internist yeah but and
that previously was Chris layman who's a
neonatal intensive guy at Vanderbilt so
you know there what's so cool I think
about the field is that the leadership
of the field is its plant specialty I am
a family physician and I was program
director for an internal medicine
fellowship which meant I had to go back
to the Graduate Medical Education
Committee that I had served on 20 years
prior as a family medicine director I
was now introducing myself as the new
program director for an internal
medicine subspecialty program which if
you told me I would be doing that 20
years I would have shot myself you know
with disbelief but and and there's a
term for it the RC calls us mongrel
program directors so there's lots of
people in terms of specialty I'm
expanding on that because it's important
to know that that's one of the things
that makes a discipline so interesting
and so confusing but it's a point well
taken in terms of the
mean to be like speaking like an insider
because I'm definitely not yeah so again
all the details they are much more well
written than my talk is but if you
really want to get into the into the
weeds and then somewhere around January
I'm sure I think Amy is going to do a
kind of a whole big reveal of a hitch
structure I don't know if they'll have
the certification process worked out by
then or not so stay tuned and I'm sure
they'll probably be some updates at the
November meeting I'm not sure how much
they're going to want to reveal at that
point okay so one minute to spare I'm
just going to thank Bill and Vishnu for
bringing me here and thank all of you
for attending today for participating
and I want to wish you all well in here
interesting new pathways to the
informatics universe good luck everybody
[Applause]